Rejoice his shame remains unknown
that he had almost
Sutter through
I don't know that poem
it's bad an uprising
it seems like a really long time since
the first season of foundation ended by
now it's even been months since the
first sneak peek for season two came out
so when I watched the full teaser that
dropped the other day I had a lot of
questions one thing I remember
distinctly from the ending of the first
season was series Creator David S goyer
saying that in his mind it ended with
the shot of Demers L tearing the skin
off her face so the epilogue of Gail
arriving on Sinex to find salvor 138
years later was the beginning of the
second season that all seems to track
with the official announcement that
Apple put out with this new teaser which
says more than a century after the
season one finale tensions Mount
throughout the Galaxy in Foundation
season 2. as the kleons unravel a
vengeful Queen plots to destroy Empire
from within Harry Gail and salvor
discover a colony of mentalx with
psionic abilities that threatened to
alter psycho history at self the
foundation has entered its religious
phase promulgating the Church of Selden
throughout the outer reach and inciting
the second crisis war with Empire the
Monumental adaptation of foundation
Chronicles the stories of four crucial
individuals transcending space and time
as the overcome deadly crises shifting
loyalties and complicated relationships
that will ultimately Define the fate of
humanity time Jump to get everyone else
caught up to where Gail and salvor are
check introduce some of the new
characters check explain how things have
developed on Terminus check what's
fascinating about this teaser then is
that it doesn't really reflect many of
those points and I'm not saying that as
a dig from someone who enjoyed asimov's
books or someone who followed the first
season closely as I covered it I'm
saying that as someone who is
legitimately wowed by how ambitious this
series is it's wild to me just how I'm
unsure I am about what's happening in
this teaser and it's kind of exciting in
that way two things that stand out here
are that the show still looks great and
the powers that be got the memo about
fans wanting more Lee Pace and the
Empire story The teaser opens with a
familiar shot of terminus and all those
markers people placed when the null
field was up in an attempt to see who
could get closest to the Vault you see
what I can only describe as an
uncharacteristically disheveled brother
day approaching the Vault he's just
wearing his under layer of chain mail
you see this in some of the other shots
which makes me think that this might be
after this later shot where it looks
like he's being attacked by or maybe
fighting with one of those Bishops claws
that are native to terminus since I
already have some good videos you can go
back and watch if you're hazy about the
details of last season I won't be
recapping everything that happened in
this but I will mention that the
foundation's plan was to use the Invicta
this to make it look like Terminus was
destroyed so that they would be free to
live there and to develop their colony
without the Empire's influence also on
Tran tour the cleons discovered that
their cloning material had been
corrupted raising questions about how
the dynasty would continue that gives
this shot a lot of baggage in the form
of questions that I can't wait to find
out the answers to in voiceover we hear
a brand new character say rejoice his
shame remains unknown that he had almost
sat a throne a much more Regal looking
brother day responds that he doesn't
know that poem and she responds it's
about an uprising Apple TV has promised
a lot of new characters for season two
and provided several descriptions about
who they are and what part they'll play
but I think this is the only one that
jumps out in this teaser it's actor Ella
Ray Smith who plays Queen sarath of
cloud Dominion her character description
reads used to being under underestimated
sarath employs it to her Advantage
Charming her way into the Imperial
Palace with biting wit all while on a
secret quest for Revenge the character
looks cool and you can also see some
clones growing in the background in this
scene
this teaser also has some Harry Selden
in it you see him with the prime radiant
and then on a ship with Gail and salvor
another thing to remember from season
one was that there was one version of
Harry in the bolt and another separate
version that Gail encountered on the
Raven which was destroyed keep in mind
that she brought Rachel's knife with her
when she went to synax though so she
would still have access to his
Consciousness it looks like they won't
be stuck on synax there are several
shots that look like completely new
planets and that promise from the
description that the three of them will
discover a colony of mentalx with
psionic abilities that threaten to alter
psycho history book readers can sort of
see where that's going but based on what
we see in the first two teasers it will
play out quite differently in the show
it looks like it'll be a lot of fun to
watch though with gravity-defying
spacers or possibly full-on robots and a
giant Mech destroying an even more giant
statue the second second bit of
VoiceOver has brother Day saying over a
hundred years ago Harry Selden stood
where you are now he claimed he could
establish a foundation to read the
future and shorten the coming age of
darkness and brother dusk responds with
the question can they read the future
it's curious because we don't know which
cleons these are or even how connected
they might be to the ones from the first
season obviously it's the same actors
playing the same roles but you imagine
that Denver Zone might have had to do
some things behind the scenes after they
found out that the samples from Cleon
the first were tampered with as well in
the time that's passed in between the
seasons they would have gone through the
cycle a few times their conversation
sounds like it could be related to
finding out what's happening in the
outer reach which they may have learned
about from Queen Sarah's visit there's
another shot of Tran tour where you see
some soldiers walking behind two
characters that are wearing red and then
later I think you see these same two
characters with Cleon standing in front
of them with a crowd looking on and he's
holding something above his head and it
kind of gives you the feeling of what we
saw in the first season when he was
dealing with thespus and anachron I'm
guessing these people are from the outer
reach they could be the connection to
the Church of Selden because otherwise I
don't see a lot of that in this trailer
you imagine the reason he goes to
terminus is because he finds out what's
happening there and then this will set
up the show's second crisis beyond that
you hear Harry saying it's time the
Empire had a reckoning and all Empires
fall and there's one shot of him where
he's looking at the ocean there's not
much demrizel here but there is one shot
of her walking and taking off her hood
on a planet where we also see a new ship
on the shore and there's a shot of her
standing behind brother day as he has an
outburst and sweeps everything off of
this table or desk there's a shot of
salvor holding the prime radiant and a
couple with her mother Gail on their new
ship in one of those you see that Mech
above them reflected in the glass and
through their window I'm not sure what's
happening but it looks great as does the
shots of the spacer slash robot
character in the sneak peek I think we
might get one shot of one of the new
book characters that are going to show
up but hopefully we'll get a full
trailer soon to sort out how everything
fits together to wrap this up some great
looking things happening here doesn't
look like they're skimping on the budget
at all so bring on Empire versus the
foundation and the Church of Selden and
let's see how the Traders fit in with
everything else that's going on can't
wait to see it and that seems like a
great place to leave things please like
this video If you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon
foreign